a movies success at the box office is no
indication of quality mediocre movies
make hundreds of millions of dollars all
the time these movies may have drawn
crowds on opening weekend only to be
almost completely forgotten in the
months and years that follow here are
the least memorable number one movies of
all time the Karate Kid
2010's the Karate Kid is less of a
remake of the 80s high school movie
classic and more a reimagining borrowing
the core concepts of the original film
it accentuates the fish-out-of-water
element of the source material by having
Jaden Smith's Dre Parker moved from
Detroit to China there he meets the
enigmatic mr. Han who teaches in the
ways of kung fu to help deal with some
school bullies it seemed to have all the
makings of a hit in the beginning of a
new era for the franchise while the
former proved to be true
the latter didn't after debuting at
number one in making Bank during its box
office run the film never caught on like
the original it may come down to
substituting simple charm with elaborate
martial arts it also doesn't help that
the film focuses on younger kids than
the originals did making it far more
cringe inducing at times a thousand
times okay this stupid now that the
original franchise has been revived for
TV
the film's long just stating sequel
seems unlikely to leave development hell
any time soon Tron Legacy hedging your
bets on an expensive sequel to a
long-dormant cult classic seems like a
bold decision but Disney went for it
with 2010's Tron Legacy the film hit
screens nearly 30 years after its
predecessor and made a solid impression
featuring some stunning special effects
bold sci-fi storytelling and a great
soundtrack by Daft Punk
it seemed Tron was back until it wasn't
it seems that awesome special effects
and weird sci-fi storytelling are
useless if they aren't anchored by
compelling characters Sam Flynn the
protagonist played by Garrett Hedlund is
a bland lead whose every line of
dialogue seemed to be ripped from a list
of the most popular movie phrases of all
time
you gotta be kidding me all the light
cycle sequences in the world couldn't
get audiences interested in his story
plans for a sequel stalled and aside
from the short-lived animated series
Tron uprising it looks like Tron Legacy
may be the last we see of the world of
the grid for some time an [ __ ] the
summer of 2008 featured the release of
Iron Man The Dark Knight and The
Incredible Hulk throw in a cinematic
adaptation of wanted and it's safe to
say it was a summer ruled by comic book
adaptations however there was another
superhero movie that dropped that summer
we're talking of course about the Will
Smith Vehicle Hancock
what the film hit number one it's
opening weekend and went on to become
the fourth highest-grossing movie of
2008 however its timing has been its
disadvantage in the long run with
recognizable name brand superhero movies
coming out every other month these days
projects like Hancock have an uphill
battle to fight for attention a sequel
has since been discussed but a decade of
Marvel and DC superhero movies
dominating the box office seems to have
put the world of Hancock on ice
Tomorrowland films based on Disney theme
park attractions tend to be hit or miss
on one hand the Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise is a huge success on the other
the less said about the country bears
the better in 2015 it looked like Disney
would have a guaranteed hit with
Tomorrowland every facet of the
production featured all stars in their
field from director Brad Bird and writer
Damon Lindelof to the film's lead George
Clooney on its opening weekend it
managed to snag the number one spot
however reception was middling at best
with reviews split almost perfectly down
the middle on Rotten Tomatoes critics
and audiences alike found it uneven at
times enthralling and exciting and at
other times utterly incomprehensible
soon hopes of a new Disney franchise
were halted in the film petered out at
the box office despite the high
expectations preceding its arrival it's
proven to be a summer blockbuster most
viewers for God as soon as they left the
theater avatar when avatar hit theaters
it mowed down box-office records like an
industrial bulldozer got a native doing
the funky chicken here it's blocking my
blade
okay Palermo it also garnered critical
acclaim even scoring a Best Picture
nomination at the Oscars it seemed like
a movie we'd be talking about for a very
long time in a genuinely shocking turn
we didn't avatar has become perhaps the
most notable instance of a massively
popular film fading into irrelevance
maybe it's the fact that viewers have
since realized that the film story is
largely derivative or maybe the real
draw was the film stunning 3d which
makes her a viewing experience that
can't really be replicated outside a
movie theater ultimately it's a tough
question the answer all we know is that
people aren't nearly as excited about
the sequels in development today as they
might have been in 2010 The Incredible
Hulk The Incredible Hulk is a perfectly
decent superhero movie with some great
moments Edward Norton is a great choice
for Bruce Banner and Tim Roth's
villainous abomination is at times
genuinely frightening it also made good
money at the box office debuting at the
top spot over its opening weekend
unfortunately it's also a movie that
audiences and Marvel have seemed eager
to forget the film came out between Iron
Man and The Dark Knight - absolute game
changers in superhero cinema and it got
lost in the shuffle pair this with
Norton and Marvel parting ways and Mark
Ruffalo stepping in his banner and The
Incredible Hulk was left on the fringes
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe The
Incredible Hulk now feels like a sort of
relic the last Marvel film to drop
before the cinematic universe era kicked
into high gear as the MCU sped along the
Incredible Hulk was left in the dust and
nobody seemed to notice the amazing
spider-man from the first big-screen
adaptation of everyone's favorite web
slinger to the characters first MCU
movie spider-man homecoming
Spidey movies have never been anything
less than box office successes mark webs
the amazing spider-man and the amazing
spider-man 2 were hugely successful well
received critically and yet completely
failed to make any sort of lasting
impression the problem comes down to how
transparent the films are about setting
up a big superhero franchise to compete
with the MCU the amazing spider-man and
its sequel may have been enjoyed by film
goers at the time but the cold
calculating vibe they give off caused
the audience to lose interest in the
long run when an opportunity presented
itself
Sony struck a deal with Marvel and
scrapped Webb's planned sequels The
Bourne Legacy The Bourne franchise
redefined action movies for a generation
and did so with Matt Damon
in the lead with the trilogy story
revolving around his character Jason
Bourne
it would seem ill-advised to make an
installment of the series that doesn't
feature him at all that didn't stop the
studio from trying in 2012 with the
Bourne Legacy the studio brought in
Jeremy Renner is Erin cross a new black
ops agent to anchor the story it's about
as good as a Bourne movie that doesn't
actually feature its title character
could be but that hasn't really proved
to be enough in the long run despite
debuting in the top spot at the box
office Renner was such a dud as the
series new lead that Damon returned for
2016's Jason Bourne now that he's back
we doubt we'll be seeing a solo Aaron
cross film again anytime soon oz the
great and powerful
in 2013 Sam Raimi offered a fresh take
on the lore of Oz with Oz the great and
powerful the movie boasts an all-star
cast that includes James Franco as the
man who had become The Wizard of Oz and
Mila Kunis as the Wicked Witch of the
West
throw in some stunning special effects
in Rainey's trademark quirk and you've
got a charming reinvention the film made
a decent critical and financial
impression upon release however the
years haven't been particularly kind to
its legacy
despite the stars being signed on for
sequels Raimi has stated he has no plans
to return to Oz anytime soon and with so
many fairy tale and fantasy adaptations
hitting screens in the years since oz
the great and powerful has become more
of a footnote than a headline
[Music]